welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navarro with an A and this is a
breakdown of the Mandalorian season 3
final trailer footage plus I'm going to
tell you everything you need to know
about all your favorite characters going
into the new season which is coming out
at midnight this Tuesday night or 3 A.M
if you're on the East Coast Eric and
Tommy asked me to recap everything ahead
of the season and is a fellow Star Wars
nerd I'm honored to oblige yep Mando's
third season is debuting on Disney Plus
on March 1st with chapter 17 written by
John Favreau before we dive in just want
to remind you that if you'd like to
support new rock stars you can by
checking out one of the great merch
options at nerdriot.shop including some
Mando inspired designs yep you can show
your support and look damn good while
doing it what a deal so let's get into
it by looking at the ready promo
released February 13th now all of these
last minute promos are showing us stuff
we've seen before but there are some
noteworthy new shots we can take a
closer look at first up we see Mando
chilling by a tree on Navarro with an E
the best Star Wars Planet this looks
like the same tree we saw the the
kawakian monkey lizard hanging out in in
past trailers so look out Mando the
kawaki monkey lizard over there then in
a shot I think we saw in the initial
season 3 trailer grief karga is walking
across the Town Square to meet Mando and
here's miscible detail number one a
little guy following Greece cargo right
behind him on the right now it goes by
in less than a blink of an eye but
knowing what we know about this town on
Navarro and what other aliens we've seen
in the previous trailer this could be an
anzelen the same alien species that Babu
frick from the rise of Skywalker belongs
to maybe the enzelans we've seen in the
trailer footage so far are all working
for karga on Navarro another example of
grief's Stellar leadership capabilities
being able to bring all types of
sentient species across the Galaxy
together working to make a better future
until the rise of the first order that
is we don't know a lot about enzelans
other than their natural scene stealer
so watch out car weathers what we do
know is that the diminutive species has
been a part of the Galaxy for at least
as far back as the high Republic era as
one and zelen was working on a solar
array station right before the great
hyperspace disaster and another named
Shug drabor even designed the extremely
expensive hotel in Orlando the Halcyon
star Cruiser and zealans are usually
helpful with jobs involving Tech because
their eyes can see microscopic details
maybe grief cargo is employing them for
good reasons they can see details other
species can't and also to make sure
Greece's luxurious Cape isn't collecting
too much dust what are you doing back
there little guy what do you doing in
the previous trailer when the enzelans
react to the scuffle going down outside
it looked like they may be tinkering
with an IG series Droid maybe they've
been tasked with bringing ig-11 back
online and bringing back Taiko ytt to
voice him let's do it in another new
shot we can see just a metric ton of
mandalorians including PODS of Isla
front and center forming up for an
attack and if you thought the
Magnificent Seven we saw in the first
trailer was a lot of mandalorians we
counted no less than 21 Mandos backing
up bisla as he fires away on his heavy
Blaster Cannon in another detail we
noticed that like before the Mando's
assembling for this season are a diverse
bunch of all different kinds of colors
and designs but now we can also add
shapes and sizes to that list of
differences because we think we may even
see Mandalorian children possibly
foundings like din jarin was himself as
a child running back behind pause Vizsla
to get cover or possibly form up for a
more strategic attack these are
Mandalorian kids after all probably
skilled in the art of kicking asses the
last we saw of pause Vizsla he was
losing a battle for the darksaber
against din jarin on the underside of a
space station also we can't help but
wonder if we'll see the Mandalorian
Creator John Favreau make a physical
Cameo appearance this season as he's
voiced Vizsla since season one sure
pause Vizsla has also since season one
been portrayed physically by actor and
stunt performer Tate Fletcher who also
played a guy who got his ass kicked by
Mando in a bar in the first episode but
there is Believe It or Not action figure
precedent for assuming Vizsla looks like
John Favreau underneath his helmet a
special edition of the figure in the
black series by Hasbro was made to look
like Fabro as a nod to him voicing the
character and creating the live-action
Series so if the story ends up taking us
to a place where more mandalorians
accept the notion of taking off their
helmet like dinjarin and Boca tan craze
have then maybe Favreau won't be able to
resist putting on the armor and taking
off that helmet for at least one iconic
shot how could you not John Favreau did
say in the promotional video showcasing
the global phenomenon the show turned
out to be that the story is quote about
becoming part of something larger than
yourself maybe the Mando's teaming up
with din will see the light take up that
helmet actually you know what we're not
sure if these Mandalorian kids are
foundlings or if Paz Vizsla might have
been getting busy to further the house
Vizsla line of succession to have a
worthy heir to reclaim the darksaber
which is his family's ancestral sword I
want an ancestral sword that's cool in
another new shot we see the squad of
Mandos descending on Navarro and one of
them attacking a weak way with what
looks like the butt of a rifle a lot of
members of the weakway species are known
to be Pirates and mercenaries like the
famous Hondo anaka who helps you take
control of the Millennium Falcon at
Disneyland why this particular weak way
is being attacked non-lethally as
opposed to just being smoked by a
Mandalorian Blaster shot isn't clear but
our guess is that grief carga ends up
needing help defending Navarro from
dangerous and opportunistic criminals
trying to wrestle control back from
cargo maybe this or other mercenaries
need to be captured for questioning to
get to the bottom of the entire
operation or maybe just to face Justice
this is a new era for Navarro after all
last new shot we see is one of who
appears to be doctor Pershing creeping
down a spooky hallway and I'm not gonna
lie looking pretty fly while doing it
you go and meet up tahi looking good to
meet up tahi now this may be the good
doctor returning to the scene of the
crime the abandoned genetics lab on
Navarro trying to find some remnant of
his work probably the early plans for
the somehow return of Palpatine or even
before that the creation of supreme
leader snoke we Star Wars sequel fans
are stoked that this era of The Saga is
being expanded upon and with the help of
Dave filoni no less the man some would
say was responsible for beautifully
fleshing out the lore and mythology of
the Star Wars prequel era in a way those
films never really have the running time
to do imagine getting to revisit the
sequels after more and more quality
storytelling like Star Wars the Clone
Wars or the Mandalorian gets to expand
some of its Concepts and ideas very
exciting next let's take a look at the
recap promo that was out on February
15th okay so in the first super fast
part we get a new shot of grief karga
giving us some grief because he looks
absolutely pissed that someone
interrupted his meeting with Mando could
it be an end Ellen updating him on some
tech issue probably not that was an eye
level stare down in enzelans are short
Kings we also get Bo Katan shooting some
blasty blasts and this was a surprise
the armorer gets into the action
slamming down on a quaren with her
patented Gravity Hammer which I believe
is also a weapon in fortnite this really
helps to sell the idea that Mando season
3 is going all out everyone's getting in
on the action and all armored hands are
on Deck maybe this is after din jarin is
able to be redeemed in the Living Waters
beneath the minds of Mandalore and even
the armorer accepts him back into their
covert speaking of towards the end of
the recap promo we see this absolutely
awesome shot of presumably Mando and
grogu arriving on Mandalore I love how
we see the N1 Naboo Starfighter slicing
through the midst of the clouds over the
ruins of sundari the mix of practical
aerial footage with an artist rendering
of a cityscape inspired by Ralph
bakori's lived-in style for the original
trilogy has always been what the
Mandalorian has been best at then we get
a badass bokeh tan sitting on her throne
looking very very much like mbaku from
Black Panther now before we head into
the minds of Mandalore those cool green
lit caves we gotta point out this detail
the pattern on the palace spiers while
Mando makes his way down to Boca tan
this symbol may be the symbol for the
house Crees the political faction that
bocatan and her sister Duchess sateen
Crees belonged to now that Beau is in
charge well maybe they've redecorated
and speaking of sateen just a reminder
she was Obi-Wan Kenobi's main love
interest in the Star Wars saga as shown
in the Clone Wars animated series could
we see a live-action flashback to that
time period Well Disney did just get
Ewan McGregor back on the payroll is all
I'm saying and finally we got some cool
quick shots of an asteroid fight maybe
one that Boba Fett can assist in a shot
proving the need for seat belts and
Mando's N1 Starfighter and another shot
of all the Mandos again with Paws Vizsla
front and center just absolutely rip
roaring ready to go and kill some guys
it's gonna be rad and we can't forget
the entire scene that was released on
February 16th featuring Mando chatting
with grief cargo while a young slash old
grogu does what every kid has ever done
when taken to their dad's office spin
around in a chair now we did get some
new insight into what din jarin is up to
in the story for this new season and it
involves karga inviting him to stay and
live on Navarro Mando explains that he's
an apostate a Mandalorian who broke the
Creed but cargo rebuttals by saying
where you're from you may be in apostate
but here you'd be landed gentry a Gentry
is but we don't actually know what it is
yet but we're assuming it's positive
maybe it comes with social status and
respect the takeaway here is that cargo
wants Mando to stick around for two
reasons one he's a friend and two
Mandalorian is strong and loyal it does
not hurt to have some someone like the
deadly denjarin or even baby grogu who
can do the magic hand thingy in your
corner if things on Navarro go south and
Apollo Crete I mean brief karga knows
how important it is to have someone you
can rely on in your corner as a boxing
joke one thing we can also point out
here is the bust in the background
possibly of karga himself it really must
help to take on the responsibilities of
the high magistrate to the citizens of
Navarro maybe some grateful group made
it to show their respect behind the
scenes this could also be a reference to
Rocky Balboa getting a statue in the
Rocky series an Apollo Creed not getting
one if ig-11 gets one why not at least
they bust for grief cargo and finally he
hasn't been confirmed for the
Mandalorian season three but fans are
hoping to see former Jedi Quinlan boss
Eric's great great great great great
great great great great great great
great great great grandfather make an
appearance he was name dropped on
Obi-Wan Kenobi and had his last full
appearance in the Canon novel dark
disciple which was awesome so you should
definitely read that did I say the same
number of greats as Tommy that's another
new rock stars Easter egg for you to
find
before we wrap up here's another
reminder to support new rock stars by
checking out the new Mando collection at
nerdriot.shop follow me at Hector is
funny on social media follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for breakdowns and insight on everything
that you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign